coming up at 6 27 in your friday morning
is shaping the future beyond the 95 in
the northern 215 beltway you ready let's
go
centennial bowling
now this should sound familiar because
we've talked about it a couple of times
just want you to miss out on the
opportunity to chime in on exactly how
i-11 will traverse not only the las
vegas metro or from henderson but also
the multiple possible paths into
northern nevada so they've already had a
couple of public meetings there are
three more to go so here's one next
tuesday at the lifeguard arena in
henderson via one a week from tuesday
downtown at the regional transportation
commission offices near the county
government center they're going to wrap
up on thursday the 16th down at the
windmill library in the south valley
there are two basic paths they're
talking about one would be the 95 515 up
to and past the centennial bowl the
other would be the 215 beltway around
the valley with a couple of different
options connecting to the 95 but whether
you come to an in-person meeting or not
i urge junior traffic buddies to check
out the virtual meeting at i11nv.com
ton of stuff about the project we got
the links in the online version of this
as well as all our centennial bowling
stores the website 8newsnow.com click
traffic then driving you crazy buckle up
drive carefully put down that phone
something's driving you crazy the email
address traffic 8 8newsnow.com